veamos si podemos calcular la integral
indefinida de seno cuarto de x o seno
elevado a la cuarta de x de x y como
siempre ponle pausa el vídeo e intenta
hacerlo por tu cuenta si este fuera un
exponente impar para seno o para coseno
entonces la técnica que yo uso consiste
en lo siguiente si tenemos por ejemplo
seno cúbico de x esto lo va a separar en
dos lo va a separar como seno cuadrado
de x por seno de x y aquí para hacer un
cuadro de x aplicaría a la identidad
pitagórica de tal manera que cuando la
multiplique por seno de x ya podría
aplicar la sustitución esto ya lo hemos
hecho en vídeos anteriores y también
aplicaría si éste fuera coseno cúbico de
x o elevado a la quinta o cualquier
exponente impar pero aquí tenemos un
exponente par que hacemos la técnica que
usamos o el truco que aplicamos está
basada también el manipular algebraica
mentel integrando para llevarlo a una
forma donde podamos integrarlo con
alguna de las técnicas que ya conocemos
en este caso usaremos la identidad del
doble ángulo la identidad del doble
ángulo
sé que se no cuadrado de x es igual
un medio de 1 - coseno de 2x y como
podemos aplicar esta identidad aquí bien
nuestra integral original la podemos
escribir como la integral de seno
cuadrado de x elevado al cuadrado de x y
aquí podemos aplicar de identidad de
identidad el doble ángulo aquí tenemos
seno cuado de x que es lo mismo que esto
que tenemos acá por supuesto
entonces aplicando la identidad del
doble ángulo la integral nos queda la
integral d
un medio que multiplica a uno menos
coseno de 2x todo esto elevado al
cuadrado de x y ahora aquí podemos sacar
de la integral la constante vamos a
extraer un medio elevado al cuadrado que
es igual a un cuarto
así es que esto es igual a un cuarto de
la integral de vamos a desarrollar este
binomio elevado al cuadrado esto es uno
menos dos veces el coseno de dos equis y
más el coseno cuadrado de 2x y esto lo
estamos integrando con respecto a equis
y aquí vemos que es inmediato calcular
la integral o la anti derivada de estos
dos términos pero qué hacemos con este
término que tenemos aquí
de nueva cuenta tengo un exponente par
apliquemos la identidad del doble ángulo
para coseno sabemos que el coseno
cuadrado ahora de 2x es igual a un medio
de uno más
el coche no del doble el ángulo del
coseno de 4x
así es que sustituyendo el integral esto
nos queda igual a esto va a ser igual a
en un cuarto lo voy a dejar ahí un
cuarto que multiplica a la integral del
agua dejar del mismo color de uno menos
dos coseno de 2x más coseno cuando de 2x
que acabamos de calcular como un medio y
aquí ya voy a distribuir en un medio así
es que es un medio más un medio de
coseno de 4x de x
de equis y aquí veamos aquí tenemos un
medio no no es este se esté acá un medio
más uno son tres medios así es que al
sumar estos dos términos tenemos tres
medios vamos a describir toda la
integral ya estamos prácticamente en la
recta final esto es igual a un cuarto
del integral de tres medios menos dos
coseno de dos x más y aquí lo que voy a
hacer observó que aquí tengo coseno el
4x así es que este un medio lo va a
poner como cuatro octavos para tener
cuatro multiplicando no se va a alterar
porque voy a multiplicar y dividir entre
cuatro esto es igual a más un octavo que
multiplica a cuatro coseno de 4x y esto
que estoy haciendo es prepararme para
hacer una sustitución
aquí tenemos 4x necesitamos su derivada
que es 4 para integrar con respecto a 4x
vamos a aplicar algo que se llama la
regla de sustitución algo así como el
reverso de la regla de la cadena que es
el fundamento de la sustitución y ya
estamos listos para integrar así es que
esto es igual y aquí
hacemos unas vanguardias esto es igual a
un cuarto que multiplica a tres medios
de x menos aquí tenemos dos que es la
derivada de 2x así es que esto es igual
a menos seno de 2x veamos si está bien
la derivada de seno de 2x es 212 92 x
qué es lo que tenemos aquí perfecto y
esto más un octavo de la integral de
esto que es seno de 4x veamos si está
bien la deriva es en el 4x es 4 kos en
el 4x que es exactamente lo que tenemos
aquí y entonces ya llegamos a la meta
más la constante integración c pues es
una integral indefinida y así hemos
concluido no fue un ejemplo tan simple
pero tampoco estuvo tan complicado lo
que sí obtener la solución es sumamente
satisfactorio